mein vortrag möchte jetzt sich vor allem
mit kant beschäftigen und zwar mit dem
begriff des faktums der vernunft was ist
das eigentlich
wie ist dieses faktum der vernunft
historisch und systematisch zu verorten
historisch in konfrontation zur david
hume der sowas extrem bestritten hat wie
vielleicht kein andere philosophie der
philosophiegeschichte dass es so was wie
ein faktum der vernunft geben kann was
auch immer das faktum jetzt genau ist
und innerhalb der kantischen theorie
selbst
wie wird dieser begriff des faktums der
vernunft motiviert im kontext der kritik
der reinen vernunft und der kritik der
praktischen vernunft also dieses faktum
der vernunft liegt gewissermaßen
übergang von der ersten zur zweiten
kritik begründet da ist es strukturell
verankert und darüber soll jetzt mein
vortrag gehen
ich fange mit kant an kant sagt wie nur
wenige philosophen dass die vernunft
normativ sehr potent ist er sagt sie hat
zwei prinzipien leistet sie einmal ein
urteils oder bewertungs prinzip dass
prinzipien die operation ist nennt er
sind seinen vorlesungen der
moralphilosophie also wie kann ich
überhaupt durch die vernunft erkennen
was jetzt moralisch geboten ist was
nicht geboten ist was verboten ist den
wert ermessen kognitiv erfassen dass die
die judikative funktion und dann und das
entscheiden
auch noch ein ausübungspreis dass
prinzipien exekution ist also die
vernunft kann nach kant nicht nur
erkennen was gut und böse ist sondern
sie kann es selbst hervorbringen
sie motiviert uns zur moralisch guten
handlungs sie bestimmt unseren willen
zur moralischen handlung und das ist
entscheidend und wie ich versuchen
möchte zu zeigen liegt das faktum der
vernunft genau hier dazwischen also es
weder nur in dem prinzip jung die
obligation ist aspekt zu finden noch nur
im ausübungspreis kann dann mit dem
gefühl der am achtung genauer
illustriert das moralische gefühle
achtung ist der paradefall für dieses
ausübungspreis und ich glaube dass das
faktum der vernünftig wäre aber noch
genauer darauf eingehen nicht nur im
zweiten moment prinzip zu finden ist
sondern gewissermaßen die
die beiden umspannt oder den die einheit
gibt aber dass darauf komme ich jetzt
noch im folgenden zu sprechen ja nach
david hume ist die leistung der vernunft
ziemlich beschränkt ziemlich konservativ
also comparing of ideas demonstration
also abstrakt verhältnisse von begriffen
apriori sind die mögliche aber sind eben
mehr oder weniger analytische urteilen
und da ist nicht viel synthetisch wir
können begriffe vergleichen
das ist eine fähigkeit der vernunft nach
jung und daneben noch in fehring of
matter of fact also wahrscheinlichkeit
aussagen induktions schlüsse die aber
dann eben nicht mehr diese absolute
gewissheit haben wie sie demonstrative
vernunft operationen haben also das sind
so diese zwei grund operationen oder
leistungen der vernunft man sieht schon
im vergleich zu kant ziemlich beschränkt
ziemlich wenig und ich möchte jetzt im
folgenden dieses verhältnis von siemens
sollen mit blick auf das vermögen der
vernunft behandelt ich glaube dass die
vernunft der schlüssel zum verständnis
dieses sein sollen des problems ist bei
david hume und bei mangel kann ja jung
kennt nicht so sehr ein faktum der
vernunft sein faktum des gefühls könnte
man sagen gegen kantig habe sie ein paar
zitat ich bringe sie auf deutsch einfach
weil es einfacher ist zum unmittelbar
nachvollziehen für uns alle ich lese mal
vor es kann aber keine schwierigkeit
haben zu beweisen dass laster und trugen
keine tatsachen sind deren dasein wir
durch die vernunft erkennen können ich
denke etwa an den absichtlichen mord
betrachtet denselben von allen seiten
und sie zu ob ihr das tatsächliche oder
real existierende finden könnt was ihr
laster nimmt wie er das ding auch an
sehen mögen ihr findet nur gewisse
effekte motive willens entschließung und
gedanken
außerdem enthält der fall nichts
tatsächlich ist also nichts vernünftiges
oder wieder vernünftiges das laster
entgeht euch gänzlich solange er nur den
gegenstand betrachtet ihr könnt es nie
finden sofern ihr nicht euer augenmerk
auf euer eigenes inneres richtet und
dort ein gefühl von missbilligung
entdeckt da sind euch angesichts dieses
behandlung entsteht auch dieses gewiss
eine tatsache aber eben die selbe ist
gegenstand des gefühls nicht der fall
und ein fakt um der vernunft wie auch
jetzt immer dieses dem genitiv zu
verstehen ich kommt auch noch ein
bisschen nachher darauf dieses dieser
genitiv ihr dieses der sie liegt in euch
selbst nicht den gegenstand erklärte ihr
eine handlung oder ein charakter
verlassen hat so meint ihr damit nichts
anderes als dass ihr zufolge der
beschaffenheit ihrer natur ein
unmittelbares bewusstsein oder gefühl
des tages bei der betrachtung dieser
handlung oder dieses charakters habt
lasst und tugend können insofern mit
tönen farben wärme und kälte verglichen
werden diese sind ja nach der neueren
philosophie gleichfalls keine
eigenschaften der gegenstände sondern
perzeption des gerätes ne also es sind
qualitäten die eben nicht mit der
vernunft direkt zu tun haben sie sind
eigenständig sie stehen für sich und
sind nicht abhängig von der vernunft in
ihrer bewertung oder gar an ihre
existenz so weit geht erkannt zu sagen
dass gefühle gewisse gefühle wie die
achtung ihrer existenz der vernunft
verdanken
ja ich nehme das jetzt mal um über die
impotenz der vernunft ist vielleicht ein
bisschen provokativ aber letztendlich
sagt dass jung sagt wir drücken uns
nicht genau in philosophisch aus wenn
ihr von einem kampf zwischen effekt und
vernunft trieben die vernunft ist nur
der sklave der effekte slave der
passions- und soll es sein sie darf
niemals eine andere funktion
beanspruchen als die denselben zu dienen
und zu gehorchen
hier fand ich interessant beim erneuten
lesen diese diese normative dimension
jetzt er darüber was die vernunft zu tun
hat sie soll
denn es soll es da ja das ist vielleicht
eine andere frage welchen normativität
hier wieder reinkommt weil man kann
könnte ja sagen die vernunft ist nur
dass klar wird effekte das wäre
definitiv nein jung fordert noch dass
sie es sein soll
hier ist die frage dann an wen richtet
sich dieser imperativ vielleicht an
andere philosophen die es anders sehen
oder anders argumentieren würde
so könnte man das vielleicht
jedenfalls hier die vernunft kommt immer
an zweiter stelle sie ist nicht spontan
autonom wie es bei kontern der fall sein
wird sondern sie ist in gewisser weise
ein instrument ell
sie gibt den mittel zum zweck der
befriedigung der befolgung gewisser
inneren bedürfnisse gefühle emotionen
dann gibt es hier ein sehr sehr
provokatives weiteres zitat was auch
wirklich diametral dem kantischen der
kantischen konzeption entgegen steht
also ich glaube es eignet sich sehr gut
er ist ein hintergrund jung
er sagt es widerspricht nicht der
vernunft wenn ich meinen vollständigen
ruinen auf mich nehme um das kleinste
unbehagen eines indianers oder einer mir
gänzlich unbekannten personen zu
verhindern es verstößt ebenso wenig
gegen die vernunft wenn ich das
erkannter maßen für mich weniger guten
dem besseren vorziehen und zudem erster
und größere neigung empfinde alles für
das letzte rennen also die vernunft ist
völlig losgelöst von moralischen
angelegen erhalten
sie steht damit nicht in einer
verbindung weiters aktionen noch ein
letztes zitat zu diesem punkt
argumentiert dass die von 15 tat nicht
quelle und zur begriffe das wirklich
guten oder sichtlich bösen sein kann da
sie durch ihren widerspruch oder durch
ihre zustimmung niemals unmittelbar eine
handlung verhindern oder hervorrufen
kann
auch das ist wirklich kontrast zu kant
kann behauptet gerade das dass die
vernunft quelle das sittlich guten und
bösen ist sie ist der grund dafür
und sie kann durch das gefühl der
achtung selbst handlungen motivieren den
willen bestimmen und am ende eine
behandlung hervorbringen zugang also
wieder hier direkt der kontrast zu kant
das jetzt nur als ein hintergrund und
jetzt möchte ich vor diesen sehr
beschränkten restriktiven vernunft
verständnis von david hume was dieses
verhältnis von seinen sollen betrifft
auf kant eingehen und wasser kann über
das sollen ganz interessant in der
kritik der reinen vernunft also ich bin
jetzt ein paar zitate aus dieser ersten
kritik das scheint mir fast so eine art
von
bezug auf jun zu sein auf diese bekannte
passage die wir heute schon mehrmals
gehört haben wo er zunächst einmal recht
gibt partiell gemäß seinen stunts seinem
trans and arlen idealismus ergibt den
part der richter sagt das soll drückt
eine art von notwendigkeit und
verknüpfung mit gründen aus in der
ganzen natur sonst nicht vorkommen der
verstand kann von dieser nur erkennen
was da ist oder gewesen ist oder sein
wird es ist unmöglich dass etwas darin
anders sein soll als es in allen diesen
zeit verhältnissen in der tat ist ja
dass sollen wenn man bloß den lauf der
natur vor augen hat hat ganz und gar
keine bedeutung wir können gar nicht
fragen was die natur geschehen soll
ebenso wenig als was für eigenschaften
ein zirkel haben soll sondern was darin
geschieht oder welche eigenschaften der
letztere hat also hier wirklich die
unterscheidung von deskriptive in der
natur das ist der diese sphäre vom
starken den normativen was eben nach
kann nicht in der natur zu finden ist
was aber gleichwohl eine existenz hat
nur eben in einer anderen sphäre da geht
es mal ein bisschen allgemein im bereich
der vernunft und jetzt stellt sich
natürlich die frage wie hängen dann
bereich der vernunft wo normativität das
sollen real ist mit der natur den
erscheinungen zusammen kann will ja kein
journalismus haben er will ja nicht dass
das reich des seins und das sollen star
koexistieren möchte fusionieren und das
ist ja die leistung seines trans and
arlen idealismus und da kommt jetzt der
begriff des des wollens ins spiel als
der wille ist sagen ein scharnier würde
ich sagen der wille gibt den übergang
von der vernunft als bestimmbare objekt
hin zur handlung die sich auch in der
erscheinung anzeigt sagt es mögen noch
so viel natur könnte sein die mich zum
wollen antreiben noch so viele sinnliche
anreize so können sie nicht dass sollen
hervorbringen soll nur einen noch lange
nicht notwendiges sondern jederzeit
bedingt das wollen dem dagegen dass
sollen dass die vernunft ausspricht maß
und ziel ja verbot und ansehen
entgegensetzt
also hier kommt der wille ins spiel es
geht kant um das unbedingte wollen das
absolute wollen das wollen was durch
reine praktische vernunft und nicht eben
durch empirisch kontaminierte vermischte
vernunft bestimmt wird und hier ist
jetzt ganz entscheidend die bestimmung
der natur der vernunft nach kant und das
betrifft diese frage wie der deskriptive
bereich der sinnlichkeit mit dem
normativen bereich der vernunft co
existiert wie hängen die beiden bereiche
miteinander zusammen werden kann ja
keinen tourismus im starken sinne
vertreten möchte er sagt dazu folgendes
es mag ein gegenstand der bloßen
sinnlichkeit das angenehme oder auch der
reinen vernunft dass gutes sein
so gibt die vernunft nicht demjenigen
grunde der empirisch gegeben ist nach
und folgt nicht der ordnung der dinge so
wie sie sich in der erscheinung
darstellen dass wir also die deskriptive
welt sondern macht sich mit völliger
spontanität eine eigene ordnung nach
ideen und jetzt kommt in die sie die
empirischen bedingungen hineinpasst und
nach denen sie sogar handlungen von
notwendig erklärt die doch nicht
geschehen sind und vielleicht nicht
geschehen werden von allen aber
gleichwohl voraussetzt dass die
vernünftige beziehung auf sie kausalität
haben könne
denn ohne das würde sie nicht von ihren
ideen wirkung in der erfahrung erwarten
ich habe diese passage fett markiert das
scheint mir der zentrale schlüssel sein
für den übergang vom seien auf sollen
vom sollen auf sein vielleicht besser
gesagt dass gemäss trans en tal
philosophie der intelli die charakter
also das deutet in meinen augen hier
schon auf diesen charakter hin dass der
intelligente charakter den empirischen
charakter fundiert und ihm nicht
unlogisch separat entgegensteht
also das ist diese große leistung des
zentralismus dieser kompatibel ist muss
wie man auch nennen könnte von vernunft
normativität und empirischer disc
aktivitäten das zusammenzudenken in
einem fundierung verhältnis dieser
empirischen und intelligenten charaktere
das ist glaube ich der schlüssel zum
verständnis
sein sollen des problems bekannt wie
nennen sagt kant weiter diese vermögen
verstand und vernunft vornehmlich wird
die letztere ganz eigentlich und
vorzüglicher weise von allen empirisch
bedingten kräften unterschieden da sie
ihre gegenstände blues nach ideen erwägt
und den verstand danach bestimmt der
denn von seiner zwar auch rein begriffen
einen empirischen gebrauch macht und
jetzt kommt dass diese vernunft und
qualität habe wenigstens wir uns eine
dergleichen an ihr vorstellen ist aus
den imperativen klar welche wir in allen
praktischen den ausübenden kräften als
regeln aufgeben also die frage wie das
sollen wie der bereich der vernunft
faktisch wird hat nach cannes zu tun mit
einer kausalität und diese kausalität
sagt kann jetzt in der ersten kritik in
der kritik der reinen vernunft hier an
dieser stelle die hat etwas mit
imperativen allgemein zu tun
hier ist jetzt noch offen ob damit auch
hypothetische imperative gemeinsam das
da ist kann in der ersten kritik noch
nicht so entschieden in der zweiten
kritik sagte dann hypothetisch
imperative haben nichts mit dem sollen
starken sind zu tun dass die
instrumentelle vernunft die er trifft
nicht den intelligent character hier in
der ersten kritik ist er in meinen augen
noch ein bisschen sehr offenes allgemein
sagt wir haben das faktum der imperative
wir verspüren imperative und darin sehen
wir dass die vernunft kausalität hat in
der kritik der praktischen vernunft hat
kant eine theorie dieser kausalität der
vernunft entwickelt die viel
spezifischer ist als diese recht vage
rede von imperativ wenn ich denke auch
daran wird klar dass er hier noch recht
offen ist also eben von imperativ
entspricht gut es gibt auch kategorische
imperativ
es gibt ja nicht nur dem hat große
sollst nicht töten du sollst nicht lügen
das sind ja alles kategorischen
imperativ
mir scheint aber hier die tatsache dass
hiervon imperativen im plural spricht
nicht von dem imperativ dass er hier
noch nicht nur moralische normativität
vor augen hat sondern auch so was die
instrumentelle vernunft denkt und das
ändert sich dann der übergang zur kritik
der praktischen vernunft wo ganz zentral
das faktum der vernunft ins spiel kommt
und so wichtig dieser begriff auch ist
erfindet sich innerhalb von kants
schriften ich habe mal nachgezählt
in dieser wendung faktum der vernunft
oder faktum der reinen vernunft nur
dreimal
also wenn man die ganzen welt gesucht zu
finden sich nur drei mal und das ist
steht im gewissen kontrast zu dieser
eminenten systematischen bedeutung
dieses begriffs und ich möchte jetzt ein
paar dieser zitate auch wieder
präsentieren die sind nicht so viele wo
man dann ein bisschen genauer sehen kann
was kann jetzt mit diesen fakten der
vernunft meint als ich möchte sie im
folgenden
gewissermaßen untersuchen was hat es mit
diesem faktum auf sich und vor allem wie
ist dieser genitiv zu verstehen faktum
der von und genäht iva es sind ja immer
ambivalent
wir können es gibt viele genitiv
auflösungen fünf genitiv gibt es
mindestens und ich will den folgenden
versuchen dass man ein bisschen
aufzudröseln aber erst wenn ich noch ein
paar zitate bringen die dieses faktum
der belegen er sagt folgendes in der
kritik der praktischen zitat man kann
das bewusstsein dieses grundgesetzes
also das sittengesetz ein faktum der
vernunft nennen weil man es nicht aus
vorhergehenden datis der vernunft zb dem
bewusstsein der freiheit denn dieses ist
uns nicht vorher gegeben heraus
vernünftigen kann sondern weil es sich
für sich selbst uns auf trinkt als
synthetischer satz a priori der auf
keiner weder raum noch empirischen
anschauen gegründet ist ob er gleich
analytisch sein würde wenn man die
begriffe wenn man die freiheit des
willens voraussetzte wozu aber als
positive begriffe eine intellektuelle
anschauen erfordert werden würde
die man hier gar nicht annehmen darf
doch muss man und dieses gesetz ohne
missdeutung als gegeben anzusehen wohl
bemerken dass es keine empirische
sonders einzige faktor der reinen
vernunft sei die sich dadurch als
ursprünglich gesetz geben können
also es gibt nur eins und das hängt mit
dem bewusstsein des vierten gesetzes
oder das ist gleichbedeutend synonym mit
dem bewusstsein des moralischen gesetzes
wie kann jetzt ein faktum etwas
tatsächliches wie kann so etwas mit
einem bewusstsein äquivalenz sein das
ist ja erstmal ein bisschen widersprüche
oder bisschen seltsam zeigen jetzt erst
ich bringe noch ein zitat er sagt dass
vorher genannte faktum ist unleugbar man
darf nur das urteil zergliedern welches
die menschen über die gesetzmäßigkeit
ihrer handlung fällen so wird man
jederzeit finden das was auch die
neigung dazwischen sprechen mag ihre
vernunft dennoch unbestechlich und durch
sich selbst gezwungen die maxime des
films bei einer handlung jederzeit an
den reinen willen halte das ist an sich
selbst indem sie sich als a priori
praktisch betrachtet dieses prinzip der
sittlichkeit nun eben um der
allgemeinheit die gesetzgebung willen
die es zum formalen obersten
bestimmungsgrenze des willens ein
angesehener subjektiven
verschiedenheiten deshalb macht erklärt
die vernunft zugleich zu einem gesetze
für alle vernünftigen wesen sofern sie
überhaupt einen willen das heißt ein
vermögen haben ihre kausalität durch die
vorstellung von regeln zu bestimmen mit
hin sofern sie der handlungen nach
grundsätzen für folglich auch nach
praktischen prinzipien apriori denn
diese haben allein diejenigen
notwendigkeit welche die 15 grundsätze
fordert fällig wird also auch hier haben
wir wieder den begriff der kausalität
war es verkannt immer ein anzeichen ist
dass es hier um die verwirklichung geht
und diese verwirklichung betrifft in
meinen augen diesen übergang vom sollen
auf sein dass nicht von seien auf sollen
sondern von der normativität der
vernunft hin zur bestimmung des willens
hin zur handlung in der welt der
erscheinung in letzter konsequenz dieses
hinein passen was kann der kritik der
reinen vernunft zu
hat letztes zitat zu diesem zu diesen
stellen über das faktum der flucht er
sagt auch ist das moralisch gesetz
gleichsam als ein faktor der reinen
vernunft dessen die uns a priori bewusst
sind und welches apodiktisch gewiss ist
gegeben gesetzt dass man auch in der
erfahrung kein beispiel da es genau
befolgt wäre auftreiben könnte also kann
die objektive realität des moralischen
gesetz durch keine der diktion durch
alle anstrengung der theoretischen
spekulativen oder empirisch
unterstützten vernunft bewiesen und also
wenn man auch die apodiktische
gewissheit auf die apodiktische
gewissheit verzichten wolle
durch erfahrung bestätigt uns so ab rost
seriös roary bewiesen werden und steht
dennoch für sich fest in der grundlegung
zur metaphysik der sitten hatte sich
kant mit der frage beschäftigt wie die
moralität reduziert werden kann
diese reduktion problematik die
reduktion des vierten gesetzes hier
jetzt in der kritik der praktischen
vernunft spielt diese fragen nach der
reduktion überhaupt keine rolle mehr
wir haben hier nach kant das
sittengesetz was apodiktisch uns vor
augen steht und zwar als etwas ja
konkretes faktisch ist also etwas
tatsächlich ist wir brauchen deswegen
nicht mehr hier die anstrengung einer
rechtfertigung zu unternehmen um die
geltung die absolute um universelle
geltung des gesetzes begründen zu können
das ist jetzt erst mal ein starkes stück
und da kann man natürlich sagen ja warum
sollten wir zum faktum der vernunft
annehmen das ist doch einfach nur so
behauptet dahin gesagt ich kann nur dann
kann ich dagegen sagen nein es gibt eben
kein faktor der vernunft
wieso das sagt er jetzt einfach mal so
ist einfach so ein trockenes versichern
und er sagt dann noch an anderer stelle
sei das kredit eve des moralischen
gesetzes und und sagt also hier braucht
keine reduktion ich möchte jetzt darauf
aber nicht weiter eingehen können
eingehen und das stellt uns jetzt die
frage nach der genauen bedeutung von
faktum der vernunft konkret nach diesen
genitiv noch diese genitiv bindung und
ich habe jetzt mal so drei formen drei
bis viermal versucht zu analysieren aber
wir können sagen genitiv subjektives
oder passives das faktum gehört zur
vernunft es gehört der vernunft es
gehört zur vernunft also der subjektives
es gehört der vernunft die vernunft ist
im besitz des faktums so ein bisschen
schwierig den tebus objektives die
vernunft ist ein faktum sie ist faktisch
gemacht und dann was mir jetzt am
plausibelsten erscheint die fünf ist der
autor danny thewes auto riss sie ist der
autor des faktums sie ist autonom aber
eben nicht nur in dem sinne als sie das
faktum hervorbringt sondern dass sie
sich gewissermaßen darin selbst zeigt im
sinne dieser struktur der autonomie der
vernunft also meine these ist dass ich
im fall der stalker des faktums der fünf
die struktur der autonomie der vernunft
zeit die selbst gesetzgebung eine eine
geschlossene struktur und ich glaube
dass wir mit dem auto riss am besten
fahren beim verständnis der des faktums
der vernunft mir ist ja auch noch
wichtig zu betonen dass das faktor fünf
nicht einfach nur eine vorliegende
objektive tatsache oder realität ist
sondern dass wir das faktum auch
grammatikalisch betrachten müssen als
ein perfekter es ist perfekt etwas
perspektivisches also es ist etwas
gemachtes und da ist ein prozess
dahinter also ein performative vollzug
eine tatsache würde ich sagen es ist
nichts gegenständliches und eine form
des bewusstseins das faktum der vernunft
ist nichts einfach nur vorliegende
sondern bewusstseins form eine manifeste
selbstbezüglichkeit der rein praktischen
vernunft als reine praktische vernunft
in ihrer selbstbezüglichkeit die als
solche faktisch wird sich irgendwie
bemerkbar macht selbstbewusst sagen was
faktisch wird dann war sie schon gesagt
habe mir scheint dass fakten der fünft
ist strukturell analog mit der autonomie
der vernunft dieses selbst
gesetzlichkeit dieses
selbstbezüglichkeit die geschlossenheit
und zuletzt wie ich am anfang schon kurz
gesagt hatte im fakten der vernunft
corinne zitieren principi um die
operation ist und prinzipien exekution
ist also durch das faktum der fünf wird
uns die absolute geltung des sitten
gesetzes deutlich bewusst apodiktisch
bewusst wir haben unsere erkenntnis
funktion damit aber eben nicht nur
sondern das moralische wird im faktum
auch eben konkret wirklich nicht nur
abstrakt denkt möglich oder abstrakt
bestimmbar sondern das moralische wird
realisiert sozusagen und deswegen würde
ich eben sagen 'das im faktum der
vernunft der übergang vom seien auf
sollen vollzogen wird der findet nicht
einfach nur stadt sondern das ist eine
leistung und diese leistung verdankt
sich der freiheit das objekt also ein
autonomer akt der dem faktum der
vernunft sekunde liegt deswegen ist
faktum eben glaube ich falsch verstanden
als tatsache man müsste es wirklich als
tatsache als vollzug dynamisch verstehen
jetzt gibt's dieses bekannte
gegenbeispiel jetzt wagt man sich wie
wie hat jetzt dieses faktum der fünf
konkret geltung konkrete wirkung und
kant hat ja ein sehr martialisch es bei
spiel gebracht dieses bekannte galgen
beispiel aus der kritik der praxis
dürfte ich möchte einfach nur kurz vor
lesen weil es sehr anschaulich ist und
für mich die ganze sache sehr gut
beschreibt setzte das jemand von seiner
wollüstigen neigung vorgibt sie sei wenn
ihm der beliebte gegenstand oder und die
gelegenheit dazu kämen für ihn ganz
unterschiedlich ob wenn ein galgen vor
dem hause da er diese gelegenheit trifft
auf gerichtet wäre um ihn sogleich durch
nach genossen obwohl es daran zu knüpfen
er als dann nicht seine neigung
bezwingen würde man darf nicht lange
raten was er antworten fragen aber ob
fit sein fürs team unter androhung
derselben und verzögerten todesstrafe
zumutete ein falsches zeugnis wieder
einen ehrlichen mann der gerne unter
scheinbaren vorwänden verderben möchte
abzulegen ob er da so groß auch seine
liebe zum leben sein mag sie wohl zu
überwinden für möglich halte
ob er es tun würde oder nicht wird er
vielleicht sich nicht getrauen zu
versichern dass es ihm aber möglich sei
muss er ohne bedenken einräumen und hier
in diesem in diesem mit dieser
möglichkeit des einräumen da liegt für
mich stand der erste grund dieses
faktums der 5
das ist ja schon ein teil kann sagt
nämlich gleich im folgenden weiter er
die moralische akteur urteilt alte dass
er etwas kann darum weil er sich bewusst
ist dass es soll und er kennt in sich
die freiheit die ihm sonst ohne das
moralische gesetz unbekannt geblieben
wird also wir haben dieses moralische
bewusstsein was er ein aspekt dieses
faktums ist und jetzt stellt sich aber
die frage nicht nur nachdem oral
erkenntnis daneben ganz entscheidend
auch nach der ausübung wie die vernunft
am ende tatsächlich wirklich wird also
wörtlich genommen jetzt und dass er kann
folgendes denn wenn sie als reine
vernunft wirklich praktisch ist zur
beweise 25 tiere und ihrer begriffe
realität durch die tat und alles
vernünftig wieder die möglichkeit es zu
sein ist vergeblich als erkannt hatten
ganz streng anspruch vernunft muss
wirklich werden im fast schon im
wörtlichen sinne will kennt werden und
das führt mich jetzt zum schluss zudem
lehrstück der theorie der achtung und
des moralischen gefühlte achtung was
verkannt für viele für markus wilczek
zum beispiel gleichbedeutend ist mit dem
faktum der vernunft als in seiner
dissertation von unserer 92 sagt markus
wilczek das faktum der vernunft als tat
der vernunft ist die achtung
weil die achtung nach kant ein vernunft
gewirkt das gefühl ist ich komme gleich
noch ein bisschen näher da gibt es ein
beispiel dazu ein zitat zu der achtung
wo wiederfand der tat die rede ist also
fontanella sagt zieht jetzt kann von
einem vornehmen böcke ich mich aber mein
geist wirkt sich nicht ich kann
hinzusetzen vor einem niedrigen
bürgerlich gemeinen mann an dem ich eine
rechtschaffenheit des charakters einem
gewissen maße als ich mir von mir selbst
nicht bewusst bin wahrnehme bückt sich
mein geist nicht mag wollen oder nicht
und den kopf noch so hoch tragen um in
meinen vorrang nicht übersehen zu lassen
warum dass sein beispiel hält mir ein
gesetz vor das meinen eigenen dunklen
niederschlägt wenn ich es mit meinem
verhalten vergleich und dessen
bevölkerung mit hindi tunlich kite es
eben ich durch die tat bewiesen vor mir
sehe
und mag ich mir sogar eines gleichen
gratis der rechenschaft
rechtschaffenheit bei mir bewusst sein
und die achtung bleibt doch denn dabei
menschen immer alles gute mangelhaften
zuschlägt das sittengesetz durch ein
beispiel anschaulich gemacht doch immer
meinen stolz nieder
wozu der mann den ich vor mir sehe
dessen unlauterkeit die ihm die ihm
immer noch anhängen mag mir nicht so wie
mir die meinige bekanntes der mir also
im reinen licht erscheint ein maßstab
gibt achtung ist ein tribut denn wir den
verdiensten nicht verweigern können wir
mögen wollen oder nicht wir mögen
allenfalls äußerlich damit zurückhalten
zu können wir doch nicht verhüten sie
innerlich zu finden also das ist jetzt
hier wieder eine stelle und kann von
einer tat spricht durch die tat
diese wirkmächtigkeit diese wirkung
hervorhebt und jetzt möchte ich zum
schluss diese vier wie mir scheint 4 und
dimensionen der achtung nach kant mal
auflisten und schauen wie fern darin
sowas faktisches angelegt ist und
inwiefern das mit dem faktum der
vernunft übereinstimmt kann zeigt zum
einen die achtung ist ein vernunft
gewirkt das gefühl und sie ist von
empirischen gefühlen von allen anderen
gefühlen kategorisch verschiedenen das
ist als ein ganz ausgezeichnetes gefühl
das sagte eine fußnote kritik in der
grundlegung zur metaphysik der sitten
dann sagt er sie ist auch noch eine
triebfeder und zwar die einzig echte
unbezweifelbar im gegensatz zum beispiel
zum mitleid oder zu anderen gefühlen wie
liebe oder sonst da wendet sich ganz
kritisch kann dazu als achter das
ausgezahlt dann sagt einer anderen
stelle die achtung ist eigentlich kein
gefühl also widerspricht ein bisschen
dem ersten punkt sein sie ist die die
moral subjektiv als triebfeder betracht
das ist mir so die moral könnte man
sagen hat so zwei aspekten hat die
moralität hat sowas kriterien ist die
judikative
das ist dann dieses die seite des
kategorischen imperativ und sie hat so
eine exekution elle seite wie wir ganz
am anfang gesehen hat und das wäre dann
der achtung suspect also moral hat zwei
dimensionen sondern sie umfasst das die
aktiven des exekutiven das sagte im
dritten punkt und dann ganz entscheidend
dieser viertelpunkt dienst noch dazu zu
sagen gibt es sagt eigentliches achtung
nicht achtung vor dem sittengesetz
sondern eigentlich ist die achtung die
achtung vor uns selbst insofern wir das
sittengesetz beachten berücksichtigt
also auch hier gibt es wieder so eine
selbstbezüglichkeit beratung
wir kennen erkennen uns als rationale
wesen in dem wir jemanden anderen acht
erkennen wir darin dass wir eigentlich
auch vernunft wesen sind uns über unsere
sinnlichen begierde hinwegsetzen können
und darin besteht und auch die
selbstachtung ja also ich glaube dass er
gegen villa strecke möchte ich also ich
geb markus willeke recht dass
tatsächlich die achtung mit dem faktum
eine verhältnis steht ich glaube aber
dass das faktum der von weiter ist als
nur die achtung weil darin auch noch
dieses prinzip medikation ist dieses
bewusstsein des hippen gesetzes
enthalten ist gut es ist auch in der
achtung irgendwie enthalten weil kannte
ja sagt dass wir die moralische
subjektiv betrachtet aber ich möchte
gegen willaschek eben ein bisschen das
faktum der etwas weiter halten nicht nur
auf die achtung beschränken und ganz zum
schluss möchte ich noch ein bisschen
krieg kritische punkte markieren die mir
aufgefallen sind in der kantischen
theorie und des faktums der vernunft ich
glaube dass das problem darin liegt dass
es noch ein bisschen zu sehr an die
subjektivität des akteurs des
individuellen akteur ist gebunden ist um
diesen übergang vom sollen auf sein zu
leisten und ich glaube wir müssen hin zu
einer interaktive tät und
geschichtlichkeit es sondern es weg von
dieser subjektivität also wie mir
scheint dass die faktizität der vernunft
nach kant nur punktuell im individuellen
bewusstsein des akteurs aufleuchtet es
gibt kein kollektives bewusstsein des
faktors passierten gesetzes das
geschieht immer mal wieder in der
bestimmten umständen wenn dieser gemeine
man mir ein beispiel gibt dann haben
empfinde ich die achtung aber das ist
irgendwie nichts habituelle soder oder
institutionalisiertes habe jetzt schon
vorweg genommen moralische subjektivität
ist nach kant wie mir scheint auch
insgesamt etwas zu schwach um normative
tatsachen oder faktisch sollen dauerhaft
zu festigen
wir bräuchten dagegen wie mir scheint
institutionen die den dauerhaften
übergang von 10 auf sollen verfestigen
in verstetigen ihn vielleicht auch
kultivieren mit hegel wer das die
objektive geist es scheint mir hier
besser letztendlich zu passen
ja das war noch so eine kleine kritik am
ende
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit